it's time for another cookbook club
yay and i love cooking with my girls
um but it's usually kind of a hot mess
i'm not gonna lie
and i'm holding this amazing cookbook
right here
that jeffrey zakarian and madeleine and
is it anna or anna i want to make sure i
get that right
um he made this book with his two
daughters
and it is an incredible cookbook i read
it front to back and i really love it
and i can't wait
to take it home to my kids please
welcome one of my favorite chefs in the
world with his daughters
anna and madeline it's jeffrey zakarian
hi how are you um i'm star struck
because i've watched you on television
my entire like i i i just i can't
believe you're here and
your daughters are so beautiful
hi lady thank you very much
we're very excited to be on your show
and i i can't wait to actually come in
person i hope it's as soon as possible
but this is a labor of love uh and uh
actually i just want to correct a little
correction this is their recipes not
mine but this is stuff that we cook as a
family all together all together we've
done this over and over and over so we
know
they work and we know there's no fuss to
them so that's i just want to
start off with that but we are so
excited to show you girls you want to
get ready
yes start
oh so i want to start with a butternut
squash soup it's one of our favorite
fall recipes
and this is one of my favorite soups in
general so we're going to start with
adding the apples this soup is so good
for that squash
like a party meal or uh something
because you can just have it on the
stove ready to go
and the guests can just like scoop it in
a bowl it's so simple and easy
and we love this recipe so much i have
to say a one pot
is also one of my favorite ways to cook
and it's how i started cooking
and i'm still not great but it's it's
just a lot less
intimidating yeah definitely so i have
burnt squash apples onion butter and
curry in here
i'm gonna bring this over to the stove
i'm gonna set this on like medium heat
and i'm going to add some
flour and this helps the soup to make it
really thicken it up
we're gonna add our chicken broth
the flour is kind of it acts as like a
thickener
yes yeah it kind of it helps to prevent
the soup from being so liquidy
salt and pepper
and after you simmer that this is what
it looks like in the end
yes i have it right here it's a
beautiful color
and um dad would you like to come bring
it over
to the show oh it's nice and hot it
smells so good
it's great you know it only takes like
about 30 minutes and this is one of
those kind of soups that
you put on the fire and guess what not
only does it taste good the smell when
you're cooking the curry in the apples
is amazing
okay so you're wondering what this is
this is an immersion blender
and we talk about this tool all a lot in
the book and this is
one of our favorite tools because it's
super
safe then pouring your hot soup into a
blender yes because it can burn yourself
you can burn yourself and i
just love using this and we're going to
do is you're going to stick it all the
way in so you don't want it to splash
everywhere
and i'm just gonna pulse it up and down
it's a little loud
i'm immersing the immersion blender
i love by the way is this a cordless one
uh no no it's a cord but uh they're
really incredible you know why because
like
she said it right on spot on is like you
really can
when you put a hot soup in a blender
even if you cover it and you hit the on
button
it's like a rocket because of the heat
so you got to be very careful
should we add a little cream to that yes
and i'm going to add some cream
you'll stir it around time to taste
through here's the fun part
so we put a little cream and notice we
left it kind of chunky because
i like the apple the butternut squash i
think the girls did a great job just
getting it to the right consistency so
we are gonna put a little of toasted
pine nuts on this and why do you like
these toasted now um
so it when you toast it it brings out
all the flavor and the pie nuts and
you do not want to leave the stove when
you're cooking these because they burn
really fast
just a little tip so you could use that
you could make this dairy free
with vegan butter or coconut milk so it
would be suitable if someone was dairy
free uh
in the family or gluten free so it's
really a great soup very easy to adjust
and honestly when you taste this we're
gonna have a quick picture right
by the way i've already like made a fool
of myself but that's what i do here in
this kitchen
and jeffrey as the mother of two
daughters
i i am just am so amazed
by like ladies do you love cooking i
mean
i wha what a dad to have oh my goodness
well you know we uh we cook all the time
together this
this summer this past time has provided
a lot of opportunity
to cook together if you know what i mean
let's taste this soup
is so incredible you guys really and
truly and
i really have to tell you as a true
lover of cookbooks
i am so honored and excited to have this
book on our show it's going to be on our
website
and cookbook club but i really really
love all the recipes they're delicious
they feel doable but they're still
really like
you know culinary and exquisite
and you both madeline
and anna are so incredibly impressive
and you know what you're intrepid in the
kitchen you're fearless
and you have an amazing dad and you're
carrying
his legacy and you should both be so
proud please go to the drewberrymart
show.com
for the full recipe and very and
probably most important
city harvest and jeffrey's cookbook club
pick
um will be there as well and we'll be
right back
thank you city harvest and thank you for
bringing attention
thank you guys so much
[Music]
you